l'adieu émouvant de gustavo kuerten au
public de roland garros son dernier
match à paris son dernier match à coups
les plus durs de ma vie je ressens le
thème rôle à jouer avec le soutien de la
fraude pour moi ça restera des moments
dont je me souviendrai pour toujours en
1987 2000 et 2001 ils l'ont soleil le
court central avant de s'imposer en
finale
grâce à lui le brésil découvre le tennis
et kuerten mettra du temps pour réaliser
la portée de l'événement c'est le début
d'une belle histoire d'amour avec le
public français
en fuite il est opéré à deux reprises de
la hanche celui que tous surnomment guga
n'a jamais pu rejouer sans douleur
depuis 2004 une nouvelle fois
aujourd'hui il a fait appel au médecin
le triple vainqueur de roland garros est
une proie facile pour le français paul
henri mathieu 19e joueur mondial
la rencontre est à sens unique personnes
sortent quelques jolis coups mais sans
régularité
à 31 ans le brésilien s'offre une
dernière samba paris deux heures de pur
bonheur pour lui
car sans appel 6 3 6 4 6 2 pourquoi
henri mathieu
légende du tennis la condition regarde
c'est fabuleux
à l'issue de la rencontre sous les
applaudissements nourris de ses fans le
brésilien reçoit un trophée honorifique
merci monsieur kuerten ou plutôt aux
brigades de guga